John: The economic crisis is becoming such
a crisis of actions now not taken, for employment
and the creation of equality in employment
the center of the agenda on economic policy
internationally.
In short that means government need to focus
on ensuring that the recovery translates more
quickly into employment creation.
We have to make sure that the model of economic
growth coming out of this crisis is more balanced,
more balanced between labor and capital, between
rich and poor, and between different regions
of the world like in the past.
That means also a focus on equality of employment,
creating decent work and reducing the income
gaps and inequality
Those are the challenges in which to avoid
a major social crisis down the road coming
out of this economic and financial crisis.